hey guys in this video we're gonna talk about how
to lose back fat okay now that's actually three
problems number one we have a problem with insulin
if you've been watching my other videos insulin is
the hormone that makes the muffin top and it can
extend around the back so that's one point and
then cortisol cortisol is a stress hormone course
Oh does release insulin that's from stress and
that will also cause them up on top around the
waist but the other one that's really common is
actual atrophy of your muscles in your back a lot
of people neglect the back muscles simply because
they don't see their back they see the front so
they're doing the sit-ups and the ab workouts but
the back is it's just as important so there's some
really key things to strengthen them back and also
tone it to make sure we get rid of the atrophy
is to really get rid of that back fat so number
one how do we get rid of insulin there's there's
three it's called the three essence okay number
one snacking you have to stop snacking snacking
increases insulin and so does any eating so you
really want to do intermittent fasting which
is like eat and then don't eat for a while and
then eat and don't eat okay so this whole grazing
thing five six small meals for the day is really
bad advice so we want to do snacking we want to
avoid snacking at all cost and just eat three
meals if you want to eat and go from one meal to
the next add a little bit of healthy fat to go
be able to go on further but that will put you
in a fat-burning state which you will actually
then run on your body on what's called ketones
and not glucose and you'll lower the need for
insulin so this is really important number two
of course the obvious avoid sugar I don't need
to tell you that but you probably already know
that and that's all the hidden sugars bread pasta
cereal crackers biscuits waffles pancakes muffins
sodas juice and that does include alcohol yogurt
because it has 10 grams of sugar and of course
the juice so that's really we need to avoid that
too lower insulin and then we want to spike
our greens why because greens have potassium
potassium will decrease the need for insulin in
fact insulin and potassium work really closely
together and if you can actually increase your
potassium you will lower the need for insulin and
also if you actually fix the insulin but you'll
actually start absorbing more potassium too so
they work really closely and it has to do with
the cell and the little potassium sodium pumps
that are on there and also the receptors in the
cells I'm not going to get into that but if you
do spike your greens you will actually improve
that okay that means bigger salads you can do
wheatgrass juice powder that that type of thing
as well all right now let's talk about cortisol
cortisol is a stress hormone the way you know
you have core cells you are under stress your
tolerance for stress is low people get on your
nerves easily you you don't sleep that well you
got the belly fat and it wraps around so one of
the best thing is get rid of kind of three main
stresses first of all the body stress your body
is like a sponge it holds stress it accumulates
stress over time time does not heal stress okay
all the old injuries old infections just being
in a stress State your body kind of breaks down
so what you want there's a physical technique so
I'm going to put pulling up the picture right now
all that being done and you can do it on your neck
you can do it in different parts of your body but
it's a stress extraction technique using a massage
tool that I developed that so you can use that
to remove body stress so every night that you go
to sleep you can make sure you never go to sleep
stressed but stress-free so fit mechanically we
want to release the points the epicenters of all
the stress in your body okay that's one number
two people stress okay I know you know this but
out of all the things that stress people out our
people okay mainly you know antagonist to people
people that bring you down so what I like to do
is I like to really look in my environment
who is stressing me out the most and either
avoid that person or deal with them or improve
the situation there also could be stress from
watching evening TV the news so don't watch the
news it's just recycled sensation back over and
over they're taking this one point trying to come
different spin at different ways different angles
it's okay to get the news that just make sure you
don't keep watching that same point over and over
and over and then you also have the nutritional
factors okay there are two main nutrients that
will help lower cortisol number one is violent
b1 very very important because when you're under
stress you deplete vitamin b1 b1 releases stress
it makes you feel calm it increases your tolerance
for stress and a lot of people are deficient
in b1 and it's because they're doing so many
grains and refined sugars but the best source
of the one would be nutritional yeast take a
teaspoon a day now like within about a minute
you'll just feel the difference it's like quite
dramatic and then of course the next one to be
potassium potassium is good for lowering insulin
and cortisol that comes from a lot of different
greens that you can have vegetables that type of
thing but that you cannot lower potato so just
by doing a high protein diet or anything like
that you need to add the greens because potassium
is the physiological tranquilizer it's a calming
mineral just like calcium but potassium you need
so much more in most people are deficient okay
those are the those that's like one and two now
number three or as far as the exercise goes now
there's basically four exercise that I'm going to
recommend the first one deals with the extensors
in the glutes I mean if you think about it people
are doing sit-ups right they're doing situps to
get rid of their stomach but they don't reverse
the flow so what is this the stomach its flexor
muscles that muscles that flex you so we want
to do the opposite muscles we want to work on
the extensors what are the extensors the glutes
ok the glutes are the extensors and also part of
your back muscles so what you're going to do
is you're going to lay get on your all fours
and you're gonna start doing these extensions
and I'm actually showing you a demo right now
how to do that so you want to do that probably
do is I would actually not necessarily just do
sets I would do it as long as you can be feel you
get fatigued rest for about three or four minutes
do it again until you get fatigued like majorly
fatigued and then do another cycle because you
might be able to do 25 you might be able to do
35 you might be able to do 7 so that's a good
way to judge to see how you're doing ok now the
next one is called the side push-up where you're
on your side and you're actually really working
your core from a different angle so when you do
this exercise you're working something called
obliques the side muscles that wrap around and
it's a great it's an emotion that a lot of people
do not even consider they can do or they've never
really workout they work just on one to one
dimension sit upright so this gives it another
dimension this will really help toned waist kay
the third one it's called the side position and
hold that's the one where you just get on your
side and you hold it as long as you can and then
you can go to the other opposite side as long as
you can go back and forth I would do three cycles
and I'd probably do that every other day this one
is good because it helps you create stability it's
kind of like a yoga move but it actually builds
up your core which is your midsection now the
last one is called the back arch this is just
a straight reversal of the sit-up it's really
good for low back pain and it's really good for
people that do too many sit-ups you lay in your
stomach and you arch back and again you're gonna
be probably for this one you'll probably do sets
of maybe 12 to 15 three sets of that make sure
you rest maybe four minutes in between but what
you want to do is you really want to work that
back get the tone back we're not necessarily
burning calories for this we're getting the
muscles to be more toned to get to develop the
back muscles because that is an area that so many
people never even work those muscles so they just
start fall apart all right go ahead and apply this
information and I will see you in the next video